clickbait man this finale it took me
around the world and back like three
separate times this is not a confession
it is a death threat no has nick ever
been violent
adrian i want to ask you first what was
your reaction to learning nick's fate it
would be really scary if it wasn't so
sad
you know the fact that we're all
swept up in media to such a degree that
we can't really tell what's what you
know on a certain level we're all fakers
you know so it just it's it's a lesson
for all of us to start looking at how we
consume media what we believe what we
create what we put out in the world and
taking responsibility for that because
we're all complicit in this
this crazy world
oh jesus
for fans who are now they've binged the
series and they're going to tune into
this interview you know what is that um
final word of closure that you can offer
fans who just went on this wild journey
with your character nick
resist
the instinct to point the finger
and get somebody and and find out who it
is because you might be wrong and in
this day and age you probably are now
betty i wanna go to you there's a lot of
chatter about want and demand for a
season two you know following sophie and
her family with you know navigating life
after nick's passing are there
conversations about doing a part two and
and what would you want to see happen
um there have not been conversations
about uh season two i think
given the nature of the story i i feel
it's quite
complete and
i would probably personally want to see
a completely different story being told
with different faces different
characters different problems
all related to uh
the internet and the social media
sphere and how we
interact with it which is very i mean
that's just it's just
creates so many universes and
how it affects us all nothing about
season two has been talked about so it
it
who knows
okay adrian if there was a season two
would you want to come back maybe in
like flashback scenes yeah of course
yeah i mean my character is told in
memory form anyway mostly in just like
you know inklings of
of people's minds so i i think i could
be
in all the seasons
yeah cheers to that i would love to see
it and i think i want to compliment you
know the the creators and the producers
of the show as well as the two of you
because i i think clickbait is so much
more than just like a murder mystery
type of show it's really a commentary on
social media and adrian for you i read
that you recently relocated to texas
and hopefully you're enjoying a more
tranquil quality of life out there um
i'm curious how much did hollywood and
click bait culture factor into your
decision to to move i'm just trying to
get away from 5g
yeah
tell me no i um
yeah i i did make a conscious choice to
to get more in into nature and be more
grounded in my life there's something
about you know our digital lives that
disconnect us from the world ironically
even though it connects us with the
entire world it disconnects us from that
sort of immediate um
intimacy with one another and with
nature so
yeah i mean that's part of my my choice
making for sure
and betty how do you navigate
hollywood and click bait culture with
your work as an actress and a public
figure uh well i i'm not on social media
so that's one way of doing with it
dealing with it um
do you pay attention to social media
even though you're not on it do you pay
attention to it not really because i i i
just know myself i i don't think it it's
the best thing for me i'm learning to
sort of
filter and protect my
my aura but i definitely can let things
really pierce me in a way that's not
that's not healthy for my mental health
and
i look i i think there's no um shame in
that and i think people who
um
who can like exist in that world kudos
and i think you can be very effective as
a person on that platform as i think
adrian is you know personally i believe
you have a lot of these charities i'm
sure you use it to like really promote
them and i think that's a great thing
you should follow me you should come
over here
well truth be told and secret secret
keep it secret even though maybe a lot
of people are watching my dog does have
an account so
yet but
you can dip your toe in that way and i i
completely respect that betty you got to
protect your piece at the end of the day
do you know where nick is right now
[Music]